What's up, Marvel fans.
We're here with Chris
McKenna and Eric Sommers,
the writers of the film.
You all have so much
to juggle in this.
There are so many characters.
Where do you even begin?
We didn't know where to begin.
We honestly, we--
after the last movie,
there were a lot of different
things that we couldn't do,
and a lot of--
in a good way.
I think those kind of
limitations are good,
but once the idea of the
multiverse opened up to us,
obviously there was an
infinite number of ways to go,
and almost an embarrassment of
riches in terms of what we had
to choose from, but
also restrain ourselves,
because we knew we
had to tell one story.
Yeah, I would
just say that with
the preceding two
spider-man movies, we always
had to-- and with this one--
we had some housekeeping to do,
dealing with the larger MCU,
and other things
that had happened.
And we had limitations
always, a lot
of which were fun to deal with.
But in this one, in
addition to that,
we then just had this door
open to the multiverse,
and just truly an infinite
number of possibilities.
And it was almost overwhelming.
And it took us a long time to
just talk and talk about it,
and realize, like, what is the
most fun we could have with it?
And hopefully we did.
And with the
multiverse, we have
super villains from previous
spider-man films in this.
What was it like to write
for those characters?
Daunting.
It was really daunting.
You know, we had already watched
those movies so many times,
but now we had to
really watch them again,
and really try to live up to--
make sure we're living
up to the characters.
But you know, I mean, Sam
Raimi is a hero of us,
and Marc Webb is an
incredible filmmaker.
We wanted to do justice to the
worlds that they had created,
but also make sure that they fit
into the world that, you know,
that we've been so
honored to be a part of.
So it was a juggling
act, you know.
It really was.
It's funny.
You know, the previous
spider-man movies
are movies that I would find
myself quoting with friends,
or just in a room with
writers discussing
something for reference.
And this is the first time
where suddenly in my career
I was writing for
those characters
that I just thought were, like,
some kind of amazing reference,
or something I was a fan of.
And yeah, it was daunting.
It was daunting.
But it was also
really, really fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]